[ Laughter ]
-I'm a little irked,
and I'll get to why.
I'm not gonna let it sully
the whole proceedings.
But I'm starting from irked.
It said that Joe Biden got rid
of Daylight Savings Time.
Not true. The Senate voted
to make it permanent.
The House has yet to vote on it.
There was a vote scheduled
in March, at 1:00 p.m.
Everyone showed up at 2:00.
[ Light laughter ]
I said the "Star Trek" character
Scotty
was not in
"The Next Generation."
And if you're wondering
why your Internet was slow
last Friday,
I think it's
'cause all the tubes were jammed
with jackals telling me,
"Scotty did in fact appear
in a 'TNG' episode, 'Relics.'"
[ Light laughter ]
And this is interesting.
[ Sighs ]
[ Light laughter ]
[ Yawning ] Scotty survived
for decades in a derelict ship.
[ Snores ]
[ Light laughter ]
Ooh!
We talked about
the Mandela Effect.
The reason we were talking
about Scott in the first place
is in Star Trek, they never
said, "Beam me up, Scotty."
You know what's really nice?
Is how it's a beautiful shadow,
the way it's falling.
It's just making my head look
super symmetrical.
[ Light laughter ]
No one ever said,
"Beat me up, Scotty."
In the "Sherlock Holmes" book
by Sir --
You always leave that part out.
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle --
Sherlock Holmes never said,
"Elementary, my dear Watson."
I guess the actual line
was Watson would say
some lines like,
"Holmes, how did you deduce?"
And he'd go,
"I used my [bleep] brain, dude."
[ Laughter ]
You know, if I could go back
in time and meet anyone --
people say
if you could have dinner
with anyone, living or dead --
I think I'd most want to meet
the first guy
who said, "No [bleep] Sherlock,"
as a joke.
[ Laughter ]
It must have been amazing...
the first time.
Obviously, it gets old,
but the first time someone said,
"No [bleep] Sherlock."
First Sherlock Holmes
was like 1887,
so what do we think -- 40 years?
40 years, I would imagine,
till the first time
someone made the joke.
[ Light laughter ]
I don't know.
Maybe it's like
after the Hindenberg,
they're talking about it,
and someone says,
"I think this is gonna be
a real blow
to zeppelin commercial travel."
"No [bleep] --"
Just would have been amazing.
Milli Vanilli --
I said they were caught
when their song skipped
on the "you"
in "Girl You Know It's True."
It was on the "Girl, you know."
It was right out of the --
I guess that was where they knew
the game was up.
I also said that Shoemaker
was a fan of Milli Vanilli,
and he pretty angrily
correcting me on that,
so I'm sorry.
According to him,
fans of Milli Vanilli
are known as Milli Fanillis...
or Manilliacs.
This was a joke we had.
Archeologists in Lao --
I said Laos --
recently discovered
an ancient tooth
thought to belong
to an extinct human species
that was lodged in a cave wall.
Experts believe their last words
were "not cake."
I then went on --
joke was written fine.
I then went on
and explained the joke
and said he thought the wall
was cake.
I did not realize,
and shame on me,
it was a female skull tooth --
I guess the tooth, and then
they work their way back.
Tooth, skull, body,
and then they know.
But shame on me
for assuming it was a man.
Women can also bite a wall,
thinking it's cake.
[ Laughter ]
Someone else said
that joke doesn't work
because cake
hadn't been invented yet.
Is that an invention --
cake?
Maybe go to @seacaptainpolls.
Maybe we'll put that up there.
Do you think cake
is an invention?
[ Light laughter ]
Cake hadn't been invented yet.
That's why people
were biting wall --
They were so desperate for --
That's how they were trying
to go about finding out
if it had been invented.
They were just biting
everything.
Kimmel -- oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy Kimmel last week --
you know, he got COVID.
He went on his show
after he got better,
called me out by name,
saying that of all
the talk-show hosts,
I hadn't reached out.
I apologized.
To make up for it,
I sent him here --
You watched me put the soup
in a FedEx box to send him.
Then he got COVID again.
And, obviously,
I didn't want him to have COVID,
but pretty catbird seat of me,
'cause my soup's
already en route.
[ Laughter ]
My make-up soup
is gonna arrive --
It's like no one's gonna beat
my new soup.
[ Light laughter ]
Obviously, perfect world,
he doesn't get COVID at all.
Second place is how
it's laid out for me.
Speaking of Kimmel -- and this
is why I'm a little irked --
Dear friend Jimmy Kimmel,
get well soon.
Can't host the show
'cause he got COVID again.
So who fills in for him
last night?
Sandberg --
Mulaney and Sandberg.
So when I call Sandberg,
nothing, no answer.
Kimmel calls,
"Hello, Mr. Kimmel."
[ Laughter ]
"What do you need, Mr. Kimmel?
Right away, Mr. Kimmel."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna call Sandberg
anymore.
I'm taking that out
of this equation.
I will just write him now,
see if he's available.
And we will see
if he writes back.
But, I mean, really,
pretty heartbreaking that --
I mean, it's almost like the way
the fact that he did Kimmel
and he's not showing up
for this,
it's almost like he's valuing
an 11:30 network talk show
more than "Corrections."
[ Laughter ]
I said if Trump wrote a book,
he would be the first person
in history
to write one
without ever reading one.
A very clever little jackal
pointed out at minimum,
he would be the second person
that would be true of,
because it would also be true
of the first person
who ever wrote a book.
[ Laughter ]
And there's a lot of answers
to this,
as nobody knows for sure
what the first book was.
So don't jackal me on this,
okay,
'cause there are some things
we can't know.
But based on what I did
research wise,
it was "Epic of Gilgamesh"
by James Patterson.
[ Laughter ]
Not that one.
It was his dad.
[ Light laughter ]
It was cool, he had the idea
to write a book
when he was at the airport
and he saw Hudson Booksellers.
[ Light laughter ]
Pizza Hut sent this hat.
There we go.
We had kind of mocked this up,
and then they actually
had it made.
Pizza Hut must have --
'cause Pizza Hut
is coming on to us pretty hard.
[ Light laughter ]
Pizza Hut must have --
[ Cellphone chimes ]
[ Sighs ] Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
"Are you available?"
Right now?
"Are you in the middle of it?"
Yeah.
[bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cellphone chimes ]
Alright.
[ Light laughter ]
I got to scroll back a long time
to the last time we talked.
[ Cellphone ringing ]
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Hey, what's up, dude?
-What's up, man?
-What did you do last night?
-Oh, I just hosted "Kimmel."
-[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, everybody here
is pretty bummed out
that you would do that
and not hang out with us.
-Well, you're in New York
is the problem,
why I go there.
-Hey, I've been trying to talk
to you for, like, five weeks
'cause Nic Cage
wanted you to host "SNL" as him.
-Uh-huh.
-Would you have done that?
-In a heartbeat.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay, so, I've thought a lot
about what I would write
if that happened,
and I want to give you
the presence --
the premise and the first line,
and I want you to just start.
-Okay.
You as Nic Cage walk out
to do the monologue,
but the premise
is you are John Travolta
wearing a Nic Cage face.
[ Laughter ]
And the first line of the
monologue is "Stop clapping!"
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Nic Cage ] Stop clapping!
I'm not Castor Troy!
[ Laughter ]
You don't understand!
There's been
a big miscommunication!
He's sleeping with my wife!
[ Laughter ]
Lord!
Lord, you got to believe me!
[ Laughter ]
-Did you like hosting
a talk show?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-You look really good, though.
I feel like the fact that
you did a talk show last night,
this is the best
you've ever looked on FaceTime.
-Well, I shaved my face.
Like, having to prep
for a guest,
like, it's like being trapped
hosting a dinner party.
-Yeah, I know all this.
Okay, bye.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I hosted one.
[ Laughter ]
Why would he tell me?
Literally,
it's what I do for a living.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckling ]
Where was I?
Pizza Hut's coming on to us.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza Hut --
[ Chuckling ]
Pizza -- [ Laughs ]
Alright, hold on.
I feel like the timing of that
was really inopportune,
because I feel like this joke
would have worked better.
I'm gonna pretend like
it didn't happen.
Shoot, Pizza Hut must have eaten
some of their pizza,
because, uh, they're thirsty.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza Hut is not a sponsor
of "Corrections."
I want to make that clear.
One day, they might be, however.
They obviously
watch "Corrections."
We appreciate the engagement.
Again,
pizza hats is the only product
that we're promoting today.
You can go to pizzahats.com,
I think.
I can't remember
if we bought that domain name.
I feel like we did.
Anyway,
Pizza Hut is not a sponsor.
But if they are
and all of a sudden,
you know, "Corrections" starts
"Brought to you by Pizza Hut,"
if all of you start saying,
"Oh, my God,
I can't believe you sold out,"
I want you to know that is
exactly what we will have done.
[ Laughter ]
Pizza Hut is in the mix.
We have another very exciting
product in the mix as a sponsor.
We talked about Vathers --
Werther's Originals.
This is so exciting.
We didn't even know
it was a product,
but they reached out.
It's a new candy by one of
our favorite directors here,
Werner's Originals.
[ Light laughter ]
Werner's Originals hard candy
is a delicious butterscotch,
the center of which
is a gaping void.
[ Light laughter ]
Werner's Originals,
because life sucks.
[ Light laughter ]
I feel like we maybe
just stumbled into a desk piece,
like sponsors
who aren't so great.
[ Laughter ]
Put a pin in it, Shoemaker.
Trump, we said,
he would have shot
Patriot missiles at Mexico.
Patriot missiles or anti-air.
Tomahawk missiles
would have been better.
We also said jokingly
that Mexico would obviously know
it was America.
And then we had a line
of Mexico thinking
maybe it was Costa Rica.
I'm very happy to say we have
a lot of Costa Rican viewers,
each of whom told me
that Costa Rica
has not had an army since 1948.
And let me just say,
I don't think it's a mistake
that you don't have an army.
I think it's a mistake
that you've told us.
[ Laughter ]
We're a go on Costa Rica.
I earpods.
It's either AirPods or earbuds.
It's never earpods.
It's never airbuds.
"Air Bud," of course,
was a movie
about a dog
who could play basketball.
And I was reading up
about it today.
This is really cool.
First movie written solely
so late-night comedy writers
would have something to
reference for the next 25 years.
[ Laughter ]
We're talking about
Madison Cawthorn
and said,
"Every rose has its Cawthorn."
Some botanists engaged with us.
Roses do not have thorns.
They have prickles.
There are three different
classifications of sharp points.
Thorns are modified branches.
Spines are modified
leaf structures.
Prickles have
no vascular material
and are easier to remove.
So from now on,
don't say thorns, say prickles.
Tough news for the band Poison.
[ Light laughter ]
Not that tough.
"Thorn" already doesn't rhyme
with "dawn."
[ Laughter ]
So they're already
halfway there,
if they want to go
with "prickles."
[ Light laughter ]
Hey, this was some confusion,
'cause we made a joke
'cause, you know,
Madison Cawthorn
both talked about
getting invited to orgies
by members of the GOP
and also mentioned
the GOP doing cocaine
and offering him a key bump.
We showed a photograph --
not real --
of Chuck Grassley
with a bowl of keys,
inviting the membership
to a key party,
and some of you thought
we misunderstood
what a key bump was.
We know what a key bump is.
A key bump is when you do
cocaine off a key,
and a key party
is when you throw
all of the keys in the bowl,
and you pick one out,
and that's your special friend
for the night.
I just think
the important thing to remember
is in the modern GOP,
when you see a key,
the only thing you know for
certain is it ain't for doors.
[ Laughter ]
So, last night's "Closer Look,"
we goofed on...
I guess you could say
Italian-American stereotypes.
Someone reached out
and said it was lazy.
Which breaks my heart,
because I then obviously
take this to heart.
And so I went to the office
of "Closer Look's" head writer,
[ Italian accent ]
Salvatore Gentile.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And, you know, post show,
he does not like
to be bothered.
He was eating his prosciutt...
[ Laughter ]
...dumping his biscott
in his capucchuch.
[ Laughter ]
Tiny, tiny little napkin.
It almost defeats the purpose,
'cause it covers so little
of the shirt, little napkin.
And he was like,
"Whosah this?"
[ Laughter ]
"Whosah this about a..."
Anyway,
I do think he took it.
I do think he took it
to heart.
♪ Just like every deli
has its pickles ♪
[ Light laughter ]
So that would work.
We've got three real special
kids who work on this show.
They came to us via a program
of kids who wanted
to break into the biz.
And we just try to provide them
sort of in-the-door experience.
Seth Reiss, Matt Goldich,
and Ben Warheit.
[ Laughter ]
And they write "Ya Burnt."
They're the Burn Boys.
That's how they're known
around the office.
And "Ya Burnt"
is such a great sketch.
And the one we did this week
was a lot of fun,
and there were some new moves
in it.
And hopefully
you guys enjoyed watching it
as much as I enjoyed doing it.
Now, unlike "A Closer Look --"
We plan "A Closer Look."
Each "Closer Look" is planned
a month in advance.
Whereas...
[ Laughter ]
"Ya Burnt --" they find out
about "Ya Burnt"
like an hour before we tape.
[ Laughter ]
So I don't want to be
too hard on them,
because they're just
pulling elements together.
It's really unfair
what we ask of them.
[ Laughter ]
And yet
it was both really funny
and there were no mistakes,
so I'm pretty psyched.
I do tip my cap
to the Burn Boys.
Oh, wait.
[ Laughter ]
There were a few.
We did a really --
We burned people
who post their Wordle scores.
That was it right there.
That's what it looked like.
And immediately you can see
people post it out
'cause, you know,
we're burning.
So, that is wrong.
You wouldn't have two T's
yellow.
That would be gray.
But not bad,
that one mistake.
They have an hour
to pull it together.
Oh, right.
It says right here, "AOL CD's."
Everybody said,
"Why is that an apostrophe 'S'?"
That wouldn't be that.
It wouldn't be a possessive
on "CD."
So just two.
Oh, it did say
an eight-hour road trip,
and a sentence later said
we were stuck in a turnpike
for 10 hours.
This is one person
who pointed out all these.
[ Laughter ]
Also, we even talked about it
backstage.
I said, "We're talking about
Inspector Gadget."
And I said,
"Is he from the '80s?"
And one of them --
I won't say his name,
but I will say
it's the same as mine,
said...
[ Laughter ]
"No, I think Inspector Gadget's
from the from the early '90s,"
and so that's what I said.
In their defense --
In the Burn Boys defense,
none of them have the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
So everything is a series of,
like, instincts plus guesses.
[ Laughter ]
They're very anti-technology.
They're like the Amish
without the work ethic.
[ Laughter ]
But we -- This is real.
This one killed me,
'cause, you know, I read.
Obviously,
I go through these, right?
You know that now.
I go through
all your corrections,
and there's no gatekeeping.
If you leave a correction,
I'm gonna read it.
So...
We had a joke about Jason
from "Friday the 13th"
waiting for night to fall
so that he could kill
his victims.
So, this was a comment I got
in the comments section.
"Hey. It's Scollins."
[ Light laughter ]
"This is my first-ever
YouTube comment.
Jason very often kills
during the day,
so I don't know if it's right
to say he's waiting
for night to fall.
Maybe you're thinking
of Dracula."
[ Laughter ]
And it breaks my heart,
because I have really gone
out of my way
to Scollins-proof my life.
[ Laughter ]
And for him
to just sneak in like that is --
Well, he got me.
But I do want to thank
all my writers, you know?
All jokes aside,
everything I said is true.
And I think we are done.